[Musique]
salut à toutes et à tous place à une
nouvelle grande interview sur arte
france consacre à novak djokovic
dans une interview accordée à la bbc le
serbe a déclaré récemment qu'il
préférait raté des tournois plutôt que
se faire vacciner contre le coc vie de
19 on rappelle que le numéro un mondial
de tennis a été expulsé mais janvier
d'australie pour ne pas avoir fourni de
prod de vaccination dans un pays à
cheval sur les restrictions sanitaires
on en parle avec le journaliste
commentateur de tennis l'une des voix du
tennis en france frédéric verdier
commentateurs notamment pour eurosport
ou encore amazon prime bon joueur
frédéric bonjour yugo jours à tous avant
de vous poser la première question j'ai
envie qu'on regarde ce qu a déclaré
novak djokovic récemment je soutiens la
liberté de choisir ce que vous mettez
dans votre corps pour moi c'est
essentiel c'est la liberté de choisir ce
qui est bon ou non pour vous je suis
partie prenante dans un sport mondial
qui joue dans un lieu différent toutes
les semaines je comprends les
conséquences de ma décision l'une de ses
conséquences étaient de ne pas aller en
australie j'étais préparé à ceux ci et
je comprends qu'en étant non vaccinés
aujourd'hui je ne peux pas jouer la
plupart des tournois le 4 février
dernier novak djokovic a rencontré le
président serbe aleksandar vucic il a
dit à cette occasion qu'il allait vider
tous en sac donc ça y est on y est c'est
chose faite qu'est ce que vous pensez de
cette déclaration la de novak djokovic
j'ai trouvé très soft d'abord parce
qu'il n'a absolument rien dit sur les
cds conditions de sa détention et
surtout de ce qu'on avait promis pour
l'australie et qui n'a pas été retenu
parce qu'il faut bien rappeler que si on
est à ce fiasco de la rétention djokovic
sa détention et ensuite son expulsion
l'australie c'est parce qu'il a reçu des
garanties de la part de craig tiley
directeur du tournoi de la part de
tennis australia qui visiblement n'ont
pas été tenus ils se sont bien trop
avancé pour un résultat que si djokovic
l'avait juste suspecter un résultat
comme ça il n'a même pas pris le risque
de venir en australie donc tout ça a
sauté au visage des australiens donc je
trouve sa déclaration qui est tout à
fait sauf qu'en fait ils ménagent
l'avenir
il n'a pas du tout envie d'être de
risquer d'être interdit de territoire
australien pendant trois ans c'est quand
même là bas qu'il a gagné 9 ans je laime
sur les 20 qu'il a pu gagner donc il va
pas insulter l'avenir même si
aujourd'hui paraît très improbable qu'on
autorise quelqu'un de non vaccinés à
venir en australie que ce soit en 23 ans
24 au 25 mai on sait qu'avec cette
pandémie c'est à dire qu'ils ont choisi
d'investir en australie en janvier 2003
à aujourd'hui c'est impossible oui les
conditions sont pas du tout réunies ya
aucune raison que ce qui a été interdite
aujourd'hui soit autorisé demain quand
on sait que l'australie est vraiment aux
pointes sur ce genre de l'histoire de
pas d'exception devant la mairie qui
s'était produit notamment avec le
gouvernement qui était en état de
friture sur la ligne en tout cas de
contradiction avec l'état de victoria et
avec tennis australia novak djokovic a
dit qu'ils n'étaient donc pas vaccinés
contre le coc vide il a dévoilé
publiquement mais il a dit qu'il n'était
pas anti vaccins
lui qui était avant l'open d'australie
j'ai envie de dire à l'icône des des
angles ti'vac ce malgré lui est ce que
là il se fait maintenant le porte parole
des opposants restrictions sanitaires
est ce qu'il assume je trouve pas je
pense pas qu'il assume totalement si
aujourd'hui vous grégory vous me dites
que vous détestez les abricots que vous
ne pouvez pas manger des haricots que
vous ne supportez pas les abricots moi
je peux dire de façon logique que vous
êtes anti abricots c'est vrai un trait
après coup en plus en plus je suis tombé
vraiment à pic mais djokovic est quand
même une chose qu'il faut rappeler parce
que tous ne s'en souvient pas mais c'est
très facile à sa disposition en avril
2020 dire qu'on est en plein coeur de la
quarantaine qui touchait la fois le
monde entier mais en l'occurrence le
tennis mondial en avril 2020 les
tournages sont arrêtés djokovic
participe à un live facebook avec
d'autres sportifs serbes et il dit et
encore une fois je n'invente rien il le
dit dis moi de toute façon je suis
contre les vaccins il dit ça au moment
où le vaccin n'a pas encore été trouvée
une instinct contre le coc id donc on
n'est pas en train de dire de quelqu'un
qui
est
voilà se méfie du vaccin anti copie du
vaccin de telle ou telle marque il est
contre toute forme de vaccin c'est une
philosophie après on peut la comprendre
ou pas la comprendre on peut en tout cas
voilà elle est ce qu'elle est elle
existe donc c'est tout car en fait c'est
une formule de rhétorique allant venue
devant les caméras oui oui je te
montrent bien se faire voir je passe ici
pour bien se faire voir parce qu'il a le
mérite en tout cas d'être aujourd'hui
claire et nette sur ce qui l'a interdite
sur son intention de faire et on voit
bien qu'il n'a pas du tout l'intention
de se faire vacciner ni pour roland
garros ni pour l'us open et pour quoi
que ce soit il n'y a rien qui vaille
pour lui le fait d'être vaccinés mais il
dit déjà donc là vraiment en avril 2001
moi si je dois me faire vacciner si on
oblige à faire vacciner pour voyager
participer un événement je ne le ferai
pas il le dit vraiment clairement il ya
déjà presque deux ans voyez donc on a
l'air d'être surpris aujourd'hui en tout
cas on fait mine d'être surpris il n'ya
pas être surpris en fait il a une ligne
qui est la même depuis toujours et quand
on sait le soin qu'il prend depuis
toujours de son corps même de façon
parfois quand on mystique il ya des
choses pour lesquelles il est prêt à
beaucoup de sacrifices c'est des choses
qui mangent d'autres qui ne mangent pas
voilà par exemple totalement sans gluten
le fait qu'il ait stoppé tout double u
ten dans son alimentation a totalement
changé sa vie il fait extrêmement
attention de manière presque
maladive à toutes sortes de choses pas
seulement de gluten voilà il fait
beaucoup de yoga il fait ou beaucoup
aussi de méditation enfin on va pas
rentrer dans tous les détails ça
prendrait parce que trop de temps et
donc il n'est pas du tout étonnant qui
n'est pas varié sur cette affaire de
deux vaccins et je comprends très bien
moi aujourd'hui qu'ils ne veuillent pas
être une figurante ivac parce qu'il sait
que c'est du coup très calme
relativement cher ne serait ce qu'en
termes de popularité et surtout
vis-à-vis de ses parents de ses sponsors
de tout cela on a l'impression qu'il est
malgré lui et on al'impression tunisien
oui politiquement justement est-ce que
c'est un sportif de se positionner
politiquement on voit aux états unis
certains mettre le genou à terre pour
protester contre les violences
policières la voilà c'est un domaine
complètement différent c'est les
restrictions sanitaires est ce que c'est
un sportif
d'agir comme ça politiquement moi je
pense que ça ça à mon avis c'est une
interprétation qu'on peut faire ou que
éventuellement les gens qui sont contre
le vaccin les antilles vax les antilles
parce tout ce que vous voulez
actuellement fermés ça ça ne dépasse pas
ce que je pense du luxe annonce combal
lui ce qu'il veut c'est de continuer à
faire ce qu'il a toujours fait
c'est-à-dire contrôler totalement est
quand même vachement dans le contrôle et
veut continuer à contrôler après il est
il est seul dans le milieu puisque vous
avez dans le top 100 97 vaccinés par
exemple rouillé si on trouve que le top
100 97 sont vaccinés donc il fait partie
des trois personnes sur le circuit qui
ne sont pas vaccinés en tout cas dans
les 100 premiers puits d'or dans le top
200 c'est à peu près la même chose et
dans le contrôle n'est pas dans le
contrôle de savoir s'il va pouvoir se
rendre en france pour pouvoir disputer
roland-garros prochainement parce que
roxana maracineanu la ministre déléguée
au sport a dit pour qu'un sportif un
sportif puisse venir en france il
faudrait qu'ils soient vaccinés donc
est-ce que
s'il n'y a pas de numéro un mondial en
plus qui sera plus numéro un mondial
quand tu auras quand tu auras laurent
roland garros mais je veux dire si à
pacy ya pas de novak djokovic
du côté de la porte d'auteuil
qui a le plus à perdre roland garros où
novak djokovic alors à mon avis le
tournoi un grand tournoi comme
roland-garros comme wimbledon comme à
l'us open les tournées du grand chêne
seront toujours beaucoup plus fort que
les individus ya aucune espèce d'absence
qui vraiment plante un tournoi du grand
chelem
rodger federer par exemple a une aura
formidable depuis maintenant quinze ans
on va dire quinze ans dans le monde du
tennis il ya eu plusieurs années de
suite où il n'a pas participé roland
garros le tournoi sont est finalement
très bien porter les années où nadal
n'était pas entre en très grande forme
et n'ont pas été nombreuses mais
déclarer forfait ou abandonner ou
déclarer forfait au bout de deux tours
le tournoi sonné aussi très bien remis
voilà donc il n'y a pas la moindre
absence
n'est pas on peut pallier n'importe
quelle absence je trouve quand on est un
grand événement et on parle aussi de la
coupe du monde quand l'italie ne se
qualifie pas pour la coupe du monde 2018
en russie bon bah on dit bah oui c'est
terrible c'est un grand nom du foot qui
est pas là on a vu très belle coupe du
monde 2018 en russie voyez donc là
roland garros j'ai aucune crainte
effectivement comme légalement français
et roland garros seront certainement et
sebo difficile beaucoup plus claire avec
djokovic qu'il n'a été le gouvernement
australien et tennis australia djokovic
pourra juger en connaissance de cause
oui je viens non je viens pas mais il y
aura pas cette espèce de fiasco
incroyable on l'a fait passer pour un
gangster de façon totalement scandaleuse
merci frédéric verdier pour votre
analyse du joko gates rappelle que vous
êtes journaliste de sport commentateurs
notamment par amazon prime ou encore
eurosport c'est la fin de cette grande
interview mais restait sur arte france
on se retrouve dans un instant pour une
autre grande interview avec cette fois
ci alexis troudi léger au politologue
spécialiste de la serbie il a notamment
écrit le livre et géopolitique de la
serbie aux éditions ellipses a de suite
[Musique]
salut à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
sur arte france pour la grande interview
place à une série d'entretiens pour
analyser l'expulsion de novak djokovic
d'australie en janvier dernier le serbe
joueur de tennis numéro un mondial
sanctionnée pour ne pas avoir fourni de
preuves de vaccination anti qu'ovide
dans un pays pourtant très à cheval sur
les règles sanitaires plusieurs semaines
après le joko gagne donc on accueille
sur ce plateau alexis trou de bonjour
bonjour vous êtes géopolitologue
spécialiste des balkans et auteur
notamment de deux ouvrages
géopolitique de la serbie aux éditions
ellipses plusieurs jours plusieurs
semaines même après l'open d'australie
finalement remporté par rafael nadal
dans quel état d'esprit sont les serbes
les serbes sont très sereins et
notamment noah djokovic pourquoi parce
que pour lui c'est une bataille qui va
au delà de
du problème de vaccination il se place
il faut savoir que c'est quelqu'un qui
vient du kosovo qui se souvient très
bien des bombardements de l'otan sur la
serbie et le kosovo en 99 et donc pour
lui c'est la bataille du canda liberté
contre le camp de pression vous avez dit
qu'il était
bon qui a été expulsé d'australie mais
il faut rappeler quand même aux
téléspectateurs le déroulement des faits
quand ils arrivent en australie le 13
janvier 2022 il a ses papiers en règle 1
qu'il a eue auprès de la fédération de
tennis australienne et du consul
australien et c'est durant son voyage en
avion que les australiens ont changé de
règles est arrivé en australie la suite
on la connaît pendant deux semaines il
se retrouve dans une sorte de prison
pour non respect des règles alors qu'il
avait respecté les règles c'est une
affaire sportive mais c'est une affaire
politique est également vous avez dit
qu'il se bat pour la liberté novak
djokovic on le connaît peu politiquement
parlant qui est il exactement alors si
vous voulez politiquement il n'a jamais
pris une avis n'a pas de prétention
politique en serbie ou ailleurs mais si
oui il a toujours été depuis le début
contre
mais les contraintes liées partout dans
le monde d'ailleurs un os qu vide et
donc là c'est bon exemple il est prêt si
vous voulez a sacrifié parce que pour
lui l'open d'australie c'était
l'occasion pour lui d'avoir un 10e titre
de devenir un des plus grands joueurs
sinon le plus grand joueur de tennis de
l'histoire mais il a préféré se
sacrifier inutile du grand chelem voilà
voilà 25 ans peuvent déjà se sacrifier
et ne pas être numéro 1 mondiale est
peut-être être dépassé par nadal ou
d'autres par rapport au grand chelem
pour pouvoir être du côté des gens qui
disent qu'il faut en terminer avec les
contraintes il faut comprendre que pour
les serbes comme pour djokovic qui est
issu du cochonnet toshi la bataille du
kosovo c'est quoi en 13 189 c'est une
bataille où finalement les serbes se
sacrifie et choisissent les voix céleste
plutôt que les voies terrestres et donc
accepte la victoire des troupes
ottomanes contre les serbes or en serbie
c'est une victoire c'est à dire qu'on a
gardé son identité et garder sa liberté
en se sacrifiant et donc j'ai pris vite
je place vraiment dans ce combat là il
l'a dit à plusieurs reprises et c'est
pour ça qu'il est depuis très serein
il est retourné au kosovo
à son retour d'australie il a fait le
tour des monastères il est actuellement
en pèlerinage dans le monastère le plus
important pour les serbes qui est le
master d'osterode au monténégro et
l'envoyer il est vraiment du côté c'est
une sorte de pratiquement de sacrifice
de la place du numéro mondial pour
défendre les idéaux de liberté qui doit
être ceux de tout homme la liberté un
duel la liberté de choix choisir si je
veux tel vaccin ou un autre choisir de
ne pas être vaccinées ou non etc on a vu
une image de novak djokovic avec le
président serbe aleksandar vucic les
deux hommes se sont rencontrés le 4
février dernier qui a sollicité cette
audience à ce que c'est novak djokovic
qui a demandé à voir le président serbe
est-ce que celle inverse qui a le plus à
gagner ou à perdre voulait compris celle
inverse c'est-à-dire novak djokovic et
en tant que no1 mondial a atteint des
sommets de popularité non seulement
servi mais dans le monde entier
donc il n'était pas du tout friand de
cette rencontre et si vous voulez c'est
pas la première fois qu'il rencontre
gucci tch le président serbe et parce
qu'il n'a pas vraiment ce besoin là
par exemple chaque année les joueurs de
tennis français sont accueillis dans le
club privé novak djokovic parce que la
fédération de tennis serbe est très
faible elle n'a pas les mêmes structures
préfère à son tennis française donc
c'était vous qiqihaer en beaucoup plus
intérêts et si oui c'est comme dans tous
les pays de l'est 1 et les figures
l'électricien et je me coupe mais il a
des intérêts sur le plan de vue
intérieure par rapport à des enjeux
électoraux par exemple les skis la plus
honnie daria sur le point de vue
extérieur pour
faire en sorte que la serbie soit
entendu mais sur les deux aspects du bon
à l'intérieur les élections là
comme nous en france un mois plus tôt
donc au début du mois d'avril élections
générales au parlement et la présidence
dont qui les intéresse vraiment à se
montrer défenseur des intérêts sert dans
le monde là en l'occurrence la diaspora
serbe en australie qui sont au moins 400
mines donc c'est un poids électoral
important mais surtout c'est un intérêt
vraiment par rapport au monde entier le
présent vucci tx est déjà élaboré une
politique très forte avec le président
russe poutine avec le président turc
erdogan a de très bons liens avec le
président macron est donc en accueillant
novak djokovic qui est le meilleur
diplomates de la serbie finalement il a
il à cette occasion incroyable vraiment
de récupérer cette icône l'icône de la
serbie lors de cette entrevue donc le 4
février dernier on les voit là les deux
hommes avaient se serrer la main novak
djokovic a dit qu'il allait livrer très
prochainement sa version des faits du
cogat et qu'elle pourrait être cette
version alors il y a plusieurs
hypothèses là on est de l'ordre de
l'hypothèse n'existe rien de le
démontrer- ont très vite en fait moi
j'ai fait des recherches comment est
sollicité et il se trouve que
rappelez-vous par exemple on se demander
pourquoi les bombardements américains
sur le kosovo
dès le lendemain dès le mois de juin
dick cheney a placé son neveu à la tête
de la principale mine au kosovo et là se
répète exactement la même histoire
le gouvernement précédent celui de gucci
tx et c'est pour ça que goodridge
intérêts récupérer djokovic qui était
inverse libéral dans les années 2000
avait passé un contrat avec rio tinto le
géant mondial ii
finalement du développement des
ressources minières et en serbie
ça pour conséquence de créer ces
derniers mois depuis le mois d'octobre
est bien un mouvement populaire contre
rio tinto oh non d'écologie de la
défense des intérêts écologiques or il
faut savoir que d'un côté jonah novak
djokovic a soutenu officiellement ce
mouvement écologique de protestation
populaire contre rio tinto qui est une
conquête
australienne et dont il vient et en
cherchant un peu et bien on se rend
compte que le fameux premier ministre
australien qui a changé les règles au
cours de ce vol aérien entre l'europe et
l'australie quand on parle de scott
morrison scott morrison scott morrison
lui est bien à des intérêts directs dans
rio tinto parce qu'ils aient des preuves
de sa alors oui j'ai les preuves il est
actionnaire il fait pas partie du
conseil ministration mille actionnaires
de rio tinto donc ce qui tendrait à dire
que si vous voulez au delà de la sphère
plus ben purement tennistique et puis de
la faire vraiment politique il y aura
une affaire vraiment géostratégique et
un combat quand même assez important
entre d'un côté les défenseurs d'une
multinationale et ceux dont djokovic
bien d'autres qui s'opposent à cette
multinationale et ils sont nombreux il
ya très peu de jeu selon vos dires le
joko gates est à la fois une affaire
politique interne
à la serbie avec des élections à venir
pour aleksandar vucic en sait également
qu'il ya des élections qui vont avoir
lieu fédéral en australie au mois de
juin pour scott morrison donc c'est très
politique sur le point de vue interne et
là vous parlez de géostratégie oui mais
également dans tout cela ce dépasse
largement le cadre du sport et c'est ce
qu'on n'a pas compris nous simples
citoyens bon entre le 13 et 20 jan et le
en tout cas durant le second acte et
nice merci alex flinn trop haute pour ce
développement cette analyse pour prendre
un petit peu de recul et de hauteur donc
sur cette affaire novak djokovic est
tout de suite on continue de parler de
la sphère djokovic mais du côté
australien cette fois ci on va retrouver
dans un instant robbie thompson et des
journalistes basé à sydney il va nous
parler donc de ce joker gates du point
de vue de canberra
[Musique]
de retour sur rt france la grande
interview continue pour évoquer le joko
gates on était il ya quelques instants
avec le géopolitologue spécialiste de la
serbie alexis trou d désormais on prend
la direction de sydney pour rejoindre
hobby thompson journaliste australien
pour chanel ten et paramout bonjour
robbie thomson bonjour règle plusieurs
semaines après l'open d'australie
dans quel état d'esprit sont les
australiens après cette affaire
bonjour règle je pense que vu comment ça
de voler le reste de tournoi de l'open
d'australie
honnêtement je pense que c'était plutôt
oublié certainement de côté muse de
l'actualité et par rapport à l'actualité
sportif aussi parce que c'était un grand
succès finalement pour h parti qui a
gagné en le féminine et pour les doubles
avec les special qu'est ce qu'ils ont
gagné les doutes dont les dans un
événement très joyeux très sportif donc
finalement il y avait beaucoup de bruit
avant le tournoi d'un niveau sportif
était haute au-delà de ça mais mais
finalement pour pour moi ce que je vois
c'est que c'est presque oublié chez nous
pourtant il ya quand même eu des des
commentateurs sportifs qui ont commenté
et qui ont même
insulté entre guillemets novak djokovic
qui pensait qu'il n'était pas à
l'antenne ça fait quand même beaucoup de
bruit c'est même allé jusqu'à jusqu'au
plus haut sommet de l'état absolument il
y avait des pas des insultes mais des
commentaires comment vous avez
certainement discuté entre le les chefs
d'état de la serbie en australie ça
l'est tout en haut c'était pendant une
semaine dix jours c'était le le sujet
à la télé à la radio dans les bars dans
les bas parce qu on était ouvert
finalement après des très sévères lors
qu dames les cantines mans un très dur
et très sévère donc qui a aussi joué un
rôle très important dans toute cette
histoire mais oui c'était c'était ça
fait beaucoup de bruit mais franchement
c'est au niveau sportif en tout cas on a
passé à autre chose c'est donc ici
c'est donc retomber un petit peu du côté
de l'australie mais pourtant au début du
mois de février le 4 février exactement
novak djokovic a rencontré son président
le président serbe aleksandar vucic et
il a dit qu'il allait livrer très
prochainement sa version des faits ce
qu'on attend ça du côté de l'australie
est ce qu'on a peur des déclarations à
venir de novak djokovic et quelles
pourraient être ces déclarations selon
vous il ya certainement on a entendu des
entend des rumeurs comme quoi c'est sans
ses interviews avec le police
frontalière de l'australie le bonheur
bord de police de bordeaux fausse
que c'était un petit peu chaud par
moments que c'est ça s'est mal passé
qu'il était un peu maltraité par ses
policiers
mais après donc il ya certes il peut y
avoir certainement des relations de ce
côté là franchement la plupart des
australiens en
on n'a pas d'avis sur ce site est à ce
niveau là sur ce qui se passait avec le
policier et et novak djokovic
il ya son cas est devisé l'australie à
un point il y avait les supporteurs de
novak il y avait beaucoup de servir à
beaucoup de serbes qui habite en
australie qui a qui a trouvé ça ce que
c'était mal malhonnête que ce n'est pas
juste que 2 de leur envoyer de ne pas
laisser défendre son titre ici mais il
faut comprendre que les australiens il
ya eu il ya plusieurs aspects le premier
c'est que on a vécu moi j'étais en
france en dehors les confinements mais
ils ont vécu ici deux ans très très
compliqué où les frontières ont été
fermées
si vous étiez en france en angleterre
peu importe dans le monde c'était
impossible de retourner en australie
même si vos parents étaient malades vous
avez quelque chose très important vous
avez plus de boulot vous voulez rentrer
en australie c'était pas possible
c'était non les frontières ont été
fermées après ils ont ouvert les
frontières ils ont dit il faut que vous
êtes vacciné et vous êtes australien et
vous pouvez revenez retourner en
australie donc là c'était ouvert un
petit peu moi j'ai retourné en australie
en novembre
il ya beaucoup de monde qui a été choqué
quand c'était annoncé que nos vertes
sans vaccin devenir
quoi de levure en fait une sorte de deux
poids deux mesures mais mais du coup on
se dit parce que c'est dans l'avion au
final que l'australie a décidé de
changer les règles puisqu'il avait des
papiers novak djokovic qui lui
permettait d'arriver sur le sur le sol
australien donc comment expliquer les
retournements de situation de la justice
australienne une fois exclu une fois
autorisé de nouveau exclu au final qui a
décidé d'exclure djokovic est ce que
c'est la justice australienne ou est ce
que c'est le premier ministre scott
morrison qui en même temps à des
élections fédérales très importants à
venir au mois de juin
c'est la justice qui a maintenu les
décisions de le police de la frontière
alors ce que j'ai compris et comment on
a compris ça en australie c'est que les
organes lorgues inez les organisateurs
de l'open d'australie ils ont dit nous
il faut que vous faites çà çà çà çà çà
et nous on s'occupe de votre table
examine donc votre exemption de visa
pour venir en australie mais à aucun
moment
le gouvernement avait dit c'est bon pour
sept ans valide que novak et les autres
bien en australie pour jouer l'open
d'australie donc donc ce que ce que nous
on comprend c'est que novak était donné
le feu vert par l'open d'australie mais
aucun moment pas par le justice par le
police frontalière parle par le
gouvernement donc lui il y arriver en
australie en bonbons fois d'avoir rempli
ce que lui pensait à faire mais à aucun
moment les règles avaient changé à aucun
moment c'était pour le gouvernement
s'est dit validé donc il y avait sept
problèmes qu'ils étaient déjà là comme
beaucoup de réfugiés qui arrivent en
australie des immigrés et voilà donc il
a été immédiatement mis dans ce cas là
d'un immigré pas validé pour venir en
australie donc y aller dans un hôtel
avec d'autres réfugiés immigrants en
australie est obligé de rester là ils
pouvaient pas circuler
jusqu'à 100 son cas a été traité par le
voir la justice quelle est sa sa
popularité à scott morrison le fait
d'avoir adopté un discours anti élites
comme comme celui ci
comment comment est-ce que ça à jouer et
comment se positionne l'opposition
également au gouvernement en vue de ces
élections à venir
scott morrison est assez contesté
au niveau de popularité pour l'instant
il sort pas gagnant en jouant juillet
pour les élections donc est-ce que
c'était une dernière
essaie de remonter dans l'épaule
d'essayer de remonter dans une
popularité des gens
je sais pas mais je franchement je pense
pas que ce ce cas ce sujet de novak
djokovic va jouer un rôle prépondérant
dans le
le résultat de l'élection fédérale merci
beaucoup me thompson d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
australien vous vivez en australie à
sydney vous êtes journaliste de sport
notamment à shenzhen et paramount merci
beaucoup pour avoir analysé le joko
gates
on se retrouve très vite sur rt france
vous pouvez revivre cette grande
interview sur le site arte france point
tv by
[Musique]
oui